after years of near record low rates
it's looking like the party may be over
in the mortgage market rates are moving
back up and the average 30-year fixed
mortgage rate has now broken the 5
barrier that's a far cry from rates
under 3 which was the average rate as
recently as october so how important is
that five percent number when it comes
to the housing market turns out it's
pretty important i'm going to tell you
why
just how much impact it could have and
why economists don't expect it to crash
the market
let's get into it
why is five percent an important number
it doesn't seem like much but when
you're talking about buying a house a
couple of percentage points can mean a
difference of hundreds of thousands of
dollars in just the first few months
this year the national association of
realtors found that higher mortgage
rates increase the monthly cost for a
median u.s home by 300
that means average home buyers today
will be paying 3 600 more a year than
folks who bought in january at five
percent u.s home buyers are paying an
additional 130 000 on a 30-year mortgage
for a median price tone over the life of
the loan higher rates also change who is
able to buy a year ago a potential buyer
with an income of just over sixty one
thousand dollars would be able to
qualify for a mortgage on a medium
priced home with mortgage rates at five
percent that rises to eighty four
thousand four hundred dollars
higher rates are already having an
impact on the housing market there has
been a significant decline in the number
of lower priced homes sold for existing
homes priced between one hundred
thousand and two hundred fifty thousand
dollars sales have fallen by twenty six
percent from a year ago existing home
sales fell seven percent in february
from the previous month the largest
decline in a year in fact existing home
sales have declined every single month
since august compared to their levels
the year before but falling sales aren't
bringing down prices they're still
rising at a double-digit pace that's
largely because there's so little supply
on the market and because more home
sales at higher price points raises the
median sales price economists say that
five percent number will stick out to
consumers and could make some rethink
testing the market mike fred and tony
chief economist the mortgage bankers
association tells me with rates at five
percent mba is likely going to pull back
expectations for home sales this year
the national association of realtors is
also reevaluating their forecasts for
2022. their director of forecasting
nadia evangelou tells me that rates
average five percent for the year 16
million potential home buyers will be
priced out of the market that includes
2.3 million first-time buyers according
to nar's projections
but frat and tony evangelou and other
economists still are not expecting the
housing market to go belly up this year
even with five percent mortgage rates
that's largely because even though
buying a home is getting less affordable
so is renting the average rent in the us
rose by 17 in february to a record high
according to realtor.com we millennials
are also reaching what economists call
peak home buying age and now represent
about 43 of the buyers we're a large
generation and fred and tony expects
that to be positive for the housing
market for the next couple years
regardless of what happens with the
economic and rate environment and
finally
there just isn't enough housing vacancy
rates are at all time lows across the
country so more people are having to
make the choice between sticking it out
with skyrocketing rent or stepping out
and coughing up more to buy a home
evangelo also expects inflation to cool
down this year as the federal reserve
raises interest rates and she's
predicting demand slows down that should
reign in the rapid increase in housing
prices and help affordability there were
already expectations for the housing
market to cool in 2022 mortgage rates at
five percent will add a little bit of
ice to that cooldown but seem unlikely
to end the party you know slim thug
taught us a valuable lesson about the
housing market in 2009. he said mortgage
paid off got a house that i own trade it
in the bentley call it cash for chrome
i'll see you next time
[Music]